hey guys thanks for drop shipping
company print fi you now had the chance
to win some free seven deadly sins
inspired merch just follow us on
instagram and twitter at anime uproar
find the post about the contest and let
us know which shirt seven deadly sins or
other you would like to get for free
we have bestsellers like Eskin or praise
the sun and melly Otisfield the wrath
you can check out our whole collection
of anime inspired shirts at anime out
Broadcom five winners from Instagram and
five winners from Twitter will be picked
at random and received the shirts of
their choice so be sure to enter and if
you just want to buy a shirt and support
more content like this in the process
you can do so at anime upper calm link
in the description and for fans of the
channel you can get a whole 25% off your
purchase by using the code uproar 25 at
checkout
[Music]
whatup guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we will be talking
about demon king Melly Otis and exactly
how strong our main character has become
before we get into that if you love to
some of these sins and want to see more
some Billy sends videos on this channel
let me know by smashing that like button
if you haven't don't forget to subscribe
and ring that magic youtube bell so you
don't miss new videos when they drop and
as always leave suggestions for future
videos you would like to see in the
comments below if you haven't realized
that by now there will be cutting edge
spoilers in this video I may even spoil
stuff that hasn't happened in the manga
yet you've been warned
so in the latest chapter as we know
something absolutely crazy has happened
Melly Otis with the power of the Ten
Commandments has emerged from his dark
cocoon I know that you guys are just as
hyped as I am about demon king Melly
Otis and I know that you guys really
enjoyed my how strong is the original
demon video so I just felt like I had to
do this video for myself because I
really enjoy making these types of
videos and for you guys too as far as
I'm concerned I'm blessed to be in this
position so I consider my duty to create
videos you guys want to see so let's
just get into some specifics let's start
with one molecular trapped Melly Otis in
a cocoon of Darkness Melly Otis ends up
breaking out of the cocoon by answering
his assault mode in Chapter 229 velasca
la is shocked that he was able to do it
she says that none of the Ten
Commandments were powerful enough to
break out except cell drous who would
have to use the demon Kings power to
destroy it considering the fact that
Melly Otis did not rely on the demon
Kings powers it would suggest that
without taking demon king powers into
account Melly Otis was stronger than any
one of the 10 commandments at this point
when she sees that Melly Otis has
entered his assault mode she thinks that
he will kill all the seven deadly sins
and her on the spot she says that this
is a strong Melly Otis that even the Ten
Commandments feared back when he was
their captain
thus molasse Killa suggests that this is
Melly Otis at the strongest he's been up
to this point in the manga we figure out
that at this point Mel Yoda says combat
class is 100
42,000 he is able to easily overpower
esken or until s Kannur activates the
one mode Murli explains that s Kannur
strength rises hour-by-hour
along with the Sun and at high noon it
reaches its peak during that time for
just one minute
he becomes the invincible incarnation of
power only in this one minute at this
point in the manga does s kannur have
the ability to defeat meliodas in
assault mode he takes him out with one
slash of his hand while Mele Otis's
attacks only feel like an itch to the
one however after the battle s Kannur
collapses to and Merlin reveals that the
damage s kannur suffered is much greater
than that of the captain because of
Sunshine's toll on SK Knorr human body
she also explains that after demon king
has stolen Mele Otis's emotions he's not
only regressing to the old Mele Otis as
he regresses his cruelty and strength
are becoming greater than they ever were
before so this is Mele Otis at his
strongest up to this point and he's
getting stronger even surpassing the
142,000 combat class he was clocked at
during the s Kannur fight later on
merlin comments on the miasma emanating
from le otis the negative energy within
it is growing stronger by the minute so
by no means should we assume that Mele
Otis before he enters the cocoon and
absorbs the ten commandments is at 140
mm he was clearly getting stronger and
stronger since his fight with Eska nor
by the time le otis wakes up and goes to
meet up with zell drusen esta rosa he is
able to effortlessly render esta rosa
and zelgius powerless they can't move
from the ground even when Zell just uses
the demon Kings power he even stops
Cusack dead in his tracks when he tries
to rescue zelgius at this point Cusack
is not in his powered up form but still
his power level has been clocked at
168,000 so being able to just stop one
of the strongest demons dead in his
tracks while also pinning down zelgius
and esta rosa really goes to show how
strong malleolus is at this point
Mele Otis realizes that he needs power
to break the curse that has been placed
on Elizabeth and himself
he hoped that his own power
and the power that the demon king lent
to Zell drous would be enough but he
realizes that it's not cause I'll just
admit that the power he's borrowed
doesn't hold a candle to the demon king
zone so Mele Otis comes up with another
strategy the demon king split his power
in half and then he further split that
half into the 10 commandments he picked
10 warriors and gave each of them one of
the ten fragments so that they were
strong enough to do his bidding but not
strong enough to threaten his own
position as king Mele Otis decides to
absorb all 10 commandments ie half of
the demon Kings power so that his own
power
will rival the demon Kings and be able
to break the curse as of the latest
chapter Mele Otis has accomplished this
he has absorbed all 10 commandments
zelgius even calls him the demon king
suggesting that he has surpassed his
father in power this is definitely a
possibility if we think about it he was
getting stronger and stronger after he
hit a combat class of 140 mm he was
getting stronger by the minute according
to Merlin he was able to stop zelgius
Esther OSA and Cusack at the same time
without breaking a sweat I think it's
safe to say that at this point he was
approaching a combat class of 200,000 if
he didn't even surpass it he probably
did to be honest because Luna shale who
had a combat class of 200 1000 had much
more trouble with zelgius while Mele
ODIs easily overpowered him but for
argument's sake let's say he had a
combat class of 200,000 at this point he
would be adding half of the demon Kings
power on top of his already high combat
class now since the demon king split his
power in half he has been growing larger
and gaining power by consuming living
things in purgatory so it's safe to say
that he's stronger than he used to be
but Mele Otis's own initial strength is
quite possibly enough to put him over
the top and make him stronger than his
father it must also be mentioned that in
chapter 285 Mele Otis's emotions in
purgatory had the power to destroy his
father's entire arm Mele Otis says he
was afraid of what appears to be his
original power because once awakened it
would mean that after returning to the
real world he wouldn't be able to stay
there anymore
his father is power
to stop him so let's review what we know
we know that malleolus will have his own
power which is at least around two
hundred thousand-plus the power of the
ten commandments ie half of the demon
Kings power in addition to this he has
awakened his original power that was
able to destroy his father's arm it was
the first time malleolus ever saw his
father panic we are further told that
once awakened this power is so strong
that he won't even be able to stay in
the real world the smelly otis with the
ten commandments and his original power
restored should be stronger than any
person in the real world and from the
looks of it he is even stronger than his
father after all his new grown-up
appearance would suggest that the curse
is broken
he stopped aging because of the curse
you might argue that zelgius is still
young but remember that soldiers spent
around 3,000 years sealed away while
malleolus did not so this is likely the
reason that soldiers did not change an
appearance with the curse broken it is
possible that those 3,000 years have
caught up with Mellie Otis a bit so that
he looks more like an adult after all we
can tell by their father that demons do
age eventually and do not maintain the
appearance of children forever still
though you gotta admit that malleolus
looks pretty good for being
significantly over 3,000 years old and
that is how strong Mellie Otis is he is
at this point quite possibly the
strongest character we've ever seen or
heard of in the series by the looks of
it he has at the very least gained
powers that put him on demon king and
supreme goddess level so what he does
next is the million dollar question it
seems fitting that he fights with his
look-alike mile a battle between the Sun
or the light and the darkness however I
can't see mile being able to beat him
alone after how strong Mellie Otis has
become all I know for sure is that this
manga is getting ridiculously
interesting right now I can now remember
the last time I've been this height over
manga chapters let me know what you
think is gonna happen next do you think
that Mellie Otis will turn out to be the
final villian or will his emotions make
it back to him if so who will be the
final villain is there anyone who can
stand up to Mellie Otis right now let me
know what you think I'd love to hear
from you and that's it for today's video
thank you so much for watching
if you liked this video make sure to
smash that like button to let me know
and let me know if there's a specific
character you want done next if you
still haven't be sure to subscribe for
more 7 Deadly Sins content we got your
fix right here also remember if you want
a chance to get some free 7 Deadly Sins
inspired merch follow us on instagram
and twitter at anime uproar simply find
the post about the contest and let us
know which shirt seven deadly sins or
other you would like to get for free
this includes our most popular shirts
the Eskin or praise the sun shirt and
the malleolus feel the wrath shirt you
can check out our entire collection of
anime inspired shirts at anime upper
calm 5 winners from Instagram and 5
winners from Twitter will be picked at
random and receive the shirts of their
choice so be sure to enter I will even
pin a message in the comments linking to
the exact Instagram post and the exact
Twitter post that you can use to enter
the contest and if you just want to buy
a shirt and support more content like
this in the process go to anime uproar
comm link in the description and for
fans of the channel you can also get a
whole 25 percent off your purchase by
using the code uproar 25 at checkout
thank you so much for all of your
support and until next time see us space
cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]